(soft music)
- Hey there, I'm Emily and I have little to no chill.
I wanna be a more relaxed and calm person,
so today I'm gonna be trying out three different meditations
that focus on the breath, the body and the soul.
And the real kicker is, y'all are doing this with me.
The coolest thing about these meditations is that they can
be done anywhere, your home, your office
or the great outdoors.
So wherever you are or whatever you're doing, you're ready
to meditate.
4-7-8 breathing is a really great technique if you need
to calm down quickly.
It's basically a natural tranquilizer
for your nervous system.
I'll explain the steps first
and then we'll practice it together.
So we're gonna inhale through our nose for four counts,
hold our breath for seven counts
and then exhale through our mouth and through our tongue
for eight counts.
You ready?
Let's do this!
Inhale two, three, four.
Hold two, three, four, five, six, seven.
^Exhale two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Inhale two, three, four.
Hold two three, four, five, six, seven.
^Exhale two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
^Inhale two, three, four.
Hold two, three, four, five, six, seven.
Exhale two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
Inhale two, three, four.
Hold two, three, four, five, six, seven.
^Exhale two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight.
First meditation done!
Let's go into our second meditation, the body scan.
Body scans are a super common way to meditate.
The point is to try to concentrate your mind and breath
on your different body parts.
I'm going to do mine lying down but you can practice yours
sitting or in a comfortable position.
Begin by drawing your attention inward.
Gently close your eyes.
Take a deep breath in
and a deep breath out.
Take notice of your feet and calves.
Clench the muscles if you want feeling the tension.
And release allowing your body to relax and soften further.
Put your attention on your thighs and your butt
clenching and contracting the muscles.
Take notice of what this feels like.
And release allowing your muscles to soften.
Contract the muscles in your lower back and stomach area.
Only do what's comfortable
and then when you're ready release.
Allow your stomach to soften and your lower back
to sink further into the floor or your chair.
Tighten your chest and upper back.
Recognize the tenseness you have in this area.
And release.
Allow your upper back to sink down relaxing further.
Now contract your arms and hands clenching your fists,
tensing your muscles.
And release.
Scrunch your face and your neck.
Only do what's comfortable feeling the tightness
in your face.
Now release.
Take a deep breath in and out.
Bring your mind into your body and feel yourself
in this present moment.
And when you're ready open your eyes.
Congratulations, we just did our second meditation.
Close your eyes and take a few deep breaths.
This is the heart chakra meditation.
We're gonna take some seriously delicious
good loving energy,
fill ourselves with it and then release that to the world.
As you inhale, draw in energy and light.
As you exhale, release tension and negativity.
Bring your focus to your chest
where your heart chakra is located.
Try to feel your heart as it beats within your body.
Breathe in kindness and breathe out love and gratitude.
Bring to mind someone who has shown you kindness.
In Buddhist meditations this person is often your mother
but it doesn't have to be.
Think of this generous and unconditional love
that this person has for you.
Visualize this person
sending them feelings of love and gratitude
in the form of golden light emerging from your heart chakra.
Let the light wrap around them like a stream of water.
Now visualize someone you see often
but you don't know personally.
It could be a barista at your favorite coffee shop,
someone that does some small kindness for you every day.
Visualize this person and send them feelings
of love and gratitude.
Wrap them in warm beautiful golden light.
Now bring to mind someone you don't particularly like.
Allow yourself to believe that any negative actions taken
against you were motivated by their own difficulties.
Empathize with their struggles.
Imagine the feelings of happiness they would have
if all their suffering was released.
Now visualize yourself among your infinite peers
who long for peace just as you do.
Wrap them in your golden light.
Imagine the golden light emerging from your heart chakra
and embrace them all.
Congratulations, we did it!
Three meditations, done!
Hey guys.
I hope you enjoyed the video.
Let me know what your favorite meditation is
in the comments below.
(water gurgling)